So we get to the last step of the technique in
which once we have generated test case specifications. We create test
cases starting from this specifications. This step mainly consists in a
simple instantiation of frames and it's final result is a set of
concrete tests. For our example, test frame number 36 that we
just saw, this will be the resulting test case, which has
the same ID, so that we can track it and will
specify to concrete values, not just the specification for the input elements.
So string STR will have this value. And the integer size
will have this value. And these two values satisfy what this
test case specification was. Which was, having a string contain special
characters. Here, we have two special characters, like the new line
and the tab. And, we have a size which is greater
than zero, in particular, okay? And this is a test case
that we can actually run on our code. That we can
run on the split program. So, to summarize, we perform six steps
in which we went from a high level description of what the program does, to a
set of concrete test cases. And this is
one of those test cases. So what, what we're
going to do next, we're going to do a mini-demo,
in which we do this for real. We take
the program, we identify categories, choices, constraints, and
we actually generate test frames and then test cases.